hey there I'm Malaysia Malone and I'm
Tiffany Smith for fandango and we've put
together a list of some of our most
anticipated summer movies so what do you
got first Alicia will one that web both
looking forward to Mad Max fury road now
this has been 30 years since the last
Mad Max film and this one was in
production for about 15 years usually
that means trouble for a film yeah but
that trailer oh my gosh it is dangerous
and dirty those practical effects right
on the special effects and I can't wait
see Tom Hardy and charlize theron in
this world and just speaking about the
trailer itself I'm a huge action film
fanatic the trailer starts with an
engine revving you get to the original
Mad Max vehicle in the trailer so I am
completely on board for George Miller to
take us into this world it looks so cool
go another film I'm really excited to go
back to is Jurassic world we've got
Chris Pratt in here they create a
bioengineered super Dino which can never
never never be good
seeing him save the world again and
having fuel burn produced is just
perfect well I love Chris Pratt's but I
also love Channing Tatum fan in July
we'll get to see him back as stripper
Mike in Magic Mike XXL now I know what
you're thinking sure talk all you want
to see no I'm not quite that shallow I
promise you but the first Magic Mike it
was not what you expected because it had
a really dark and interesting script and
this one looks like more of the same
plus it has a new cast and gets the case
when you dance numbers but I think it'll
be more substance than what you might
think okay I'll wait to see it and I'll
withhold judgment until I see the movie
the dancing habibi the last movie that I
want to talk about is mission impossible
5 Tom Cruise is back he is just killing
it lately edge of tomorrow is one of my
favorite films from last year and so
knowing that he's going to consistently
push himself forward and do bigger and
better stunt that's one of the main
reasons that I'm really excited
yeah i'm looking forward to that one but
one that i want to talk about is South
Pole which is out in late July it stars
my future husband Jake Gyllenhaal yes I
tell him that he does know that was you
know Dylan whole styles as a boxer he
loses everything in a personal tragedy
and then he has to fight his way back to
the top so it's a redemption story which
is always great and to see him go from
skinny and psychotic in Nightcrawler to
this buff boxer and southpaw I'm gonna
go ahead and say that this could be his
raging bull just another reason for you
to want to marry him huh well those are
just a few of the movies that we are
most anticipating for this summer let us
know some of your pics and make sure you
get your movie tickets on fandango i'm
sydney smiths and I Malaysian maligned
by